erste wort mit ihr an mit den acht räte
mit dem großen aha also tatsächlich hat
sie geschrieben höher besten auch wieder
einen scheiß kanal und steckt ihn noch
eine flasche in deinen arsch so es geht
und herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video leute ich habe heute hinter der
kamera meine mutter hat meine kamera und
zwar heute habe ich mich etwas ganz
besonderes ausgedacht ich habe mir jetzt
saftige hängt der kommentare aus dem
hinterhalt rausgezogen werde nicht
einfach so drauf reagieren weil es gab
schon 20.000 mal so dass ich werde
meiner mutter heute hält der kommentare
vor lägen aber nur einen teil davon
meine mutter muss erraten was die leute
eigentlich geschrieben haben und mich
schauen wie gut meine mutter meine
eltern kennt jetzt gemacht schreibt vor
allem ja warum musst du nur so ne sein
und dreckige deutsche youtuber nehmen
kommen wir suchen zwei wörter warum
musst du so eine und dreckige deutsche
youtuber nehmen komme also wieso zwei
wörter du sagst dummer und tust was
würdest du dir denken wenn jemand sagt
warum musst du nur so sein was könnte da
reinkommt warum musst du nur so eine
banane sein oder warum musst du nur so
eine abwasserreinigungsanlage sein
flasche flasche okay und was kommt ein
zweiter stelle
wir haben den ersten games jahre flasche
und blödmann kälte hat geschrieben warum
musst du nur so eine [ __ ] sein und
dreckige deutsche youtuber leben komma
spaß an der stelle leider bisher
vernehmen
wir kommen wir da jetzt sollte es unter
dem video einbruch bei luca der
innerlich noch ich war dabei
ja ok manche leute haben es nicht so gut
aufgefasst zum beispiel das shop du
kannst doch nicht einfach bei lux
einbrechen du du du ich bin lux und
nicht dein fan also wie beim ersten mal
schon tipp geben drei wörter das erste
pläne doch so deutlich leute können wir
wartet bitte kurz klatschen tatsächlich
wichtig das erste wort ist gut so und du
kannst nicht aber bei luca einbrechen
buchen sohn aber wir suchen weiter würde
das zweite wort fällt mit b an
er sagt du hast richtig ist der
kommentar von dir hast du alle deine
mutter schreibt aber du warst ja alles
klar sehr gut geschlagen
wir brauchen nur das dritte mord hängt
es an
[Musik]
von teenagern vor acht monaten zu einem
video www pearl westen auf mit dem
scheiß kanal und steckte noch eine
flasche dann bist du wenigstens 25 cent
wert also wir suchen drei wörter ein
wort 283 wort dann bist du wenigstens 25
cent wert blöd dass ich da was zu sagen
alles ist offen
würdest du sagen was würdest du
beschreibst umschreibt
tatsächlich hat sie geschrieben höher
besten auch mit dem scheiß kanal und
steckt ihn auch eine flasche in dein
arsch alles groß geschrieben da bist du
wenigstens 25 cent wert war deine
gedanken ja schon mittelpunkt der
kommentar ist auch von dir oder ja ja ja
das war ein kommentar von mir zu den 40
videos von lehrern red und ab marschiert
in zwei personen schauen seine eigenen
sachen es ist egal ob es fakt ist do.com
punkt du bist selber jungen du hast
selber blöde videos du bist will dann
diesmal hat und eine art von
kommunikation
aber wirklich das schlimmste rechtzeitig
da wenn du einfach zufällig
tastendrücken würdest hättest nicht so
recht schreiber ist das habe ich sofort
zwei weitere waren wir schon zwei wörter
und zwar hat schon seine eigenen sachen
es ist egal ob es fakt ist die op und
dann wenn natürlich auf die stelle dein
penis ist schwarz und eine art kokon
profi kaka kings 2 1 np hat mit peter
und dreckig wahrscheinlich ist dreckig
das wort das mit anfängt oder das hätte
mir auch gedacht an der stelle
ok und das zweite das richtig aber
erstens müsste jetzt heute ist es nicht
hilfe sondern männer
natürlich hat elsa frozen eltern
beschrieben schon deine eigenen sachen
an es ist egal ob ist fakt ist du penner
wir verlosen fenster springen oder
okay leute es ist echt krass immer wenn
ich etwas mache oder videos man ab oder
kommentiere rasten die leute aus es ist
unfassbar nix mit sex mitstreiter du
denkst auch du wärst der beste kleiner
www.hna.de schon zwei wörter richtig
dazu woche zusammen ich gar nicht sagen
ja willst du dich richtig gehört nicht
zu meiner erwarten ein gehalt das spiel
dort ist auch nicht gesagt wir tun etwas
wie bekkering auch im raum und die
sagten einfach mal die wörter
ja das ist dann halt so also leute wie
jetzt bei dem kommt oder so was ist
nicht von meiner mutter des tribeca ring
und ich finde schlecht von dir dass du
so was sagt mir bekkering also gesagt
das erste b ist pixar hast du schon
gesagt gewissen punkt ist vergessen habe
das spricht was könnte ist bei uns schon
das eine oder andere mal auch gesagt ja
das geht gar nicht so hibbelig redet
kommt immer mal was du sagst du ganz nah
er von einem unfassbaren noch video
titel wie oder dazu ich sage was ich
sage solche worte nicht wenn man also
ich verwende ich wollte nicht aber leute
ich muss wirklich sagen meine mutter hat
sich doch unterm strich grandios
geschlagen ich gehe nach dem fest davon
aus dass der eine oder andere kommentar
unter diesen videos auch von hier kommt
weil sie dich einfach zu gut damit
auskennt dank sich dabei sind mama tina
fischer leute hier könnt ihr eine folge
was geht ab check und jemand kanal
abonnieren das was man heute haut rein
lasst euch nicht runter zeigen dass du
nicht alles nicht so lasst euch einfach
nicht unterzeichnen leute